- Last time you were on,
you met Octavia Spencer,
who I love.
Yeah, so have you seen her since?
- Oh my God, first off, I
cannot say more positive things
about a person than Octavia Spencer.
I had no idea , I had no
idea, I was just gonna
completely fall in love
with her. I ran into her
at, there was like an
Oscars party, or something.
I don't know how I got
in , but I was there.
And it was like a bunch
of different actors , and
Octavia was there, like in a
group with like some pretty
big actors. Like big actors.
And I was like 'Okay, I'm gonna
go in, I gonna say hi to
Octavia . I'm gonna seem so cool
cause we know each other.' So
I go in, and I say hi to her,
she says hi, she gives me
a hug. Its like we're best
friends reunited. And I'm
like, this is going great. And
then like I talked to the other
actors there, and I'm like
really flowing. Like, my
conversation's going right now.
I'm doing a good job. So I'm like, wow,
I'm probably gonna get like
a big movie deal after this,
this is nuts. I'm the
networking king, and then I
say goodbye to Octavia,
and I'm walking away. One
of the actors call me over, and goes:
'Can you come here for a
second?' And I'm like ,
'Oh my God,'
'This is my big break.' And he
goes, he whispers in my ear,
and he goes: 'Your fly is
down, put your zipper up."
- Oh no!
- Yeah, its the worst.
The entire time, I thought I
was being so cool. I had my
fly down the entire time.
- That is like my life in a nutshell.
- Its the worst. Its the worst.
- I was like, I don't know
why these guys are laughing,
It cause they were laughing at me.
- Well they probably weren't,
everybody has stuff like that
that happened.
You know what's so cool though,
that they at least told you.
I hate when people don't tell people.
- Its the best, it takes a lot
of courage to tell somebody.
- Yes
- Especially when , I
actually never have the
courage to tell anybody. Like when my
friend has food on their
mouth, or like somebody
I don't know, like there's
food on there's mouth,
I have such a hard time
going : Hey , get the food.
I don't know why, but its such an
embarrassing conversation.
- I am the first person to
tell you if you have a booger,
your pants are unzipped,
somethings happening.
- Oh yeah?
- First person. Cause I want
people to tell me, cause I
mean, obviously, we're
all human. Stuff happens.
- Right , right , right, right.
- Natalie, my friend
and my assistant, like
literally always tells
me I have a booger so...
- Yeah, I'm just like:
you got something. Get it.
But it's a booger, it's
fine. We'll move on ,
it'll be fine.